ouvrez grand vos yeux et vos oreilles le
premier rallye électro féminin au monde
partira de versailles l'année prochaine
il est 100% électrique 100 % féminin
100% naturel
déçus par l'annulation du rallye en
bolivie auxquelles elle devait
participer
linda benzid et agnès ce gain se sont
lancés dans un sacré projet la première
a créé son entreprise naturel aventure
pour organiser ses propres rallye la
particularité seules les femmes peuvent
s'y inscrire l'objectif c'est vraiment
de faire vivre à des femmes une
expérience unique de leur apporter
tellement haut niveau au niveau
personnel
en termes d'émotion en termes de projets
et de challenge un rallye de régularité
avec horaires de départ et d'arrivée à
respecter une étape de marche
quotidienne est programmé les équipes se
rendront jusqu'en sa voix à travers des
routes pittoresques à la recherche de
beaux paysages départ donné à versailles
villes partenaires du rallye
c'est aussi un clin d'oeil historique au
départ du dakar puisque 20 ans il ya
vingt ans le dk le dakar partie de
versailles je trouve ça sympa de dire
que 20 ans plus tard c'est des femmes
qui partent à bord d'une voiture avec
trévise sur la partie de trek donc c'est
environ une dizaine de kilomètres de
trek par jour avec des challenge et des
balises à trouver
l'autre axe du projet c'est la
protection de l'environnement
d'abord les voitures sont 100%
électrique et a nié ce gain a créé une
association écologique soutenu par
nature l aventure nous allons mettre en
place des projets en faveur de
l'environnement donc l'émission en fait
de l'association c'est soutenir des
projets locaux nationaux ou
internationaux
selon les les rallyes départ de ce
premier rallye électro féminin le 9 mai
prochain
mais les deux aventurières ne compte pas
s'arrêter là une édition 2022 est déjà
prévue en france et en norvège